I wonder if I should even waste my time
reviewing this I wonder if a single one
of my lovely viewers honestly is
salivating at seeing the words
unforgettable movie review appear in
their subscription feed while on account
of the fact that I just spent $8.50
seeing it I guess are mine as well
I can probably sum up the plot in less
than 10 seconds jealous ex makes life a
living hell for her ex's new fiance Sam
that was painless
how did rosario Dawson end up in this
movie she's far too talented for this in
fact her performance is better than this
film deserves nevertheless she plays a
partially retired blog editor she's
about to get married to a handsome guy
who carries a lot of baggage from his
past relationship should I mention that
throughout the entire film I was trying
to remember where I've seen him before
only to look up his filmography and
discover that in the recesses of my mind
I recalled seeing him on an episode of
that old show S Club 7 yes definitely
mentioned that that's fucking hilarious
and absurd and I loved it do not forget
to bring up a magical website that
Katherine Heigl uses that contains
virtually all personal information she
needs to make Rosario's life a living
hell or how they apparently got the
rights to have Facebook in the film but
this chat we see is incorrectly
recreated and it uses iPhone sound
to top off the films hilariously fake
movie technology Rosario's computer
loads pictures like it's still on
dial-up from the 1999 this of course is
for dramatic effect speaking of drama be
sure to discuss the attempts at it one
scene finding Rosario tiptoeing through
her house after hearing some scary
noises only to discover that it's just a
harmless hamster I guess the raccoon
from that atrocity shut-in wasn't
available then don't even worry about
mentioning that it's written by the same
person who wrote shut in that's just too
easy with the film like this there is of
course a domestic abuse son a lot these
films that exist in the Lifetime channel
Cinematic Universe or that LCCC you
absolutely require it the filmmakers are
constantly looking for excuses for these
women to cross paths that they literally
see each other on the same street while
out for a stroll is there only one
street in the LCC you so when Heigl
starts taking items from their house
obviously no one getting suspicious she
takes a watch underwear a phone and a
wedding ring I'm sorry but a whole post
object went missing in the course of a
few days something is clearly a missed
and when I get to that point of the
review that should bring me to one of my
biggest confusions the timeline the film
starts with Rosario in an interrogation
room
then cut specific months prior after a
while we catch back up to that
interrogation scene only it feels like
at most maybe one week at Act this movie
couldn't even create a natural flow of
time how does a movie directed by a
woman and written by a woman have almost
nothing but scenes where women argue
over a guy I mean for God's sake all
this movie needs is a September release
date Screen Gems distribution and we'd
have our next win the bow breaks after
the third
public speech scene and in multiple
celebratory business dinners one wonders
if the filmmakers have any idea what
actual people do everyday because when
those scenes aren't happening it's just
Heigl glaring a lot in acting bitchy and
Rosario needing comfort from her husband
there are so many scenes where the
husband goes hey listen everything's
going to be alright that I actually lost
count I eventually just found myself
waiting for one of the girls to
inevitably grab a knife and shape the
other one through a dark house oh man
don't forget to mention the lines you
wrote down and you got it right here
where's your phone maybe I'll get a job
I do have a degree you know you're not
on Facebook or Twitter you basically
don't exist holy shit did they die go
for it Yolo
and that ended oh what a devastatingly
maddening final shock
it was either meant to infuriate the
audience or set up a sequel which for
the sake of the human race I really hope
is not the case unless they really are
trying to start an LTC you I mean why
not for getting a universal monsters
University anything can happen I guess I
will probably give unforgettable and eff
I mean I don't see any reason not to why
was it called unforgettable anyway who
cares let's just start the review
unforgettable
[Music]